ah ouais
bah je vais me prendre la première
feuille de la boîte à outils ou je vous
le dis la boîte à outil qu'est ce que
c'est une boîte où il ya des
chroniqueurs qui ont mis
des choses et des poux cave sur les
chroniqueurs et pmp il y en a qui sont
présents il y en a qui sont absents 1 à
l'époque dénoncé tout le monde sur
n'importe quoi même la personne et la
première concerne ma personne d'ailleurs
à
cyril ne regarde rarement les films
aussi d'ailleurs il sert pas par exemple
investir il regarde rarement les films
d'internaliser on a l'idée toujours de
lui résumer pour faire genre devant les
actes
source chroniqueur anonyme bernard
montiel est un bâtard
c'est toi maintenant alors oui c'est
benhaim non c'est pas moi non
sincèrement c'est pas moi de leur bon
dire du mal de vous
jamais un à ne jamais jamais d'abord
est-ce que vous confirmez la fin tu déjà
alors y'a déjà d un guitariste pour des
films je ne servais pas idem pour les
livres si par hasard vous les lésés par
et même les films de vos potes et les
pièces de théâtre mais aussi en fait
nous coûtait rien
[Rires]
ça me déçoit beaucoup je vais vous dire
ce n'est pas je vous dise cyril vous
avez de meilleures quand vous n'avez pas
vu les films et les livres et tout ça
parce que si valérie merci toujours la
pompe soit la mairie après vous avez les
traitements de faveur c'est à dire que
nous on va au projet et vous vous
recevez un lien ils sont en demande un
lien on dira non c'est pas possible et
vous vous l'avez eue c'est pas toi
c'est quoi ton
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
m
tu animes tu animes et voilà ça ne pose
pas les bonnes questions tu de moi oui
je t'aime beaucoup c'est nice a encore
si l'une à à civile est un crevard
c'est kelly b novelli je suis sûr quan
on s'imagine médecin bah oui ça il a
annulé nos stylistes pour nous filer des
bons d'achat la place
qui a dit ça mais la raison
j'ai dit ça alors la faute leur sort et
c'est peut-être quelqu'un qui est pas là
c'est pas c'est quelqu'un qui est là
mais ça fait déjà deux coups si on n'a
pas des noms déjà mais les chaussons
bébé
c'est vous dire en fait je leur ai dit
habillez-vous comme bouchaoui non
mais regardez
permet d'économiser beaucoup d'argent
c'est tout pas du tout ça que laissait
alors je vais vous dire ça nous coûte
exactement la même chose ce soit avec ce
qu'on vous donne à la série 100 euros
par mois oui matt à 100 euros soit vous
avez 100 euros par mois on n'a que des
effets que les supplie l'once en euros
par mois pour pouvoir les sept ans à
bien tous les jours le de pékin mais qui
à 100 euros par mois
mais pas 100 euros bas mais rien non
nourdine
[Applaudissements]
relevant des menteurs
[Rires]
mais on n'avait pas la confiance et
comptons il peut être le budget
auto avec 100 d'ariary la personne
accepte un cendrier à
fabriquer jamais ça vous plaît calmez
vous sinon je vais arrêter les poux qui
chacun va rentrer chez soi non visible
jusqu'à maintenant choisi là c'est bien
que ce seuil à l'acte sur moi ouais faut
dire si c'est nous pas si vous voulez
hein on a la cb c'était vous non c'est
qui
non c'est vous et que je le saurai mais
non en loge genton a dit je me laisse
jusqu'à décembre pour kate delphine 1
yvan je me rabattrai sursaut picos
[Applaudissements]
mentalement sonore je me laisse jusqu'à
novembre
novikov ses fils comme a invité à dîner
non ouais ouais ouais mais là c'est au
costes
et tu penses que tu as une chance avec
sophie koch bas 16 mai à proposer donc
il m'a dit elle échoit à bout voilà les
voir ta voiture de série j'étais chaud
non c'est ouais non ça c'est vrai amuse
toi bien là dia je vais te pêche au thon
au deuil
invité par la prod à une pièce de
théâtre valérie s'est plaint de ne pas
être reconnu d'avoir été placées au fond
avec le public land
occupé
non c'est pas vrai ou ailleurs je suis
allé voir comment josiane balasko et
bien en fait mon amoureux et moi non
n'étant pas au même endroit il en avait
placé lui là haut au poulailler et maman
vous l'ayez
la famille donc un temps et j'ai pas
voulu laisser mon amoureux tout seul
donc j'ai laissé ma place en bas je suis
monté avec mon amoureux là haut mais
c'est avec talent et même si ça c'est
tout bas
alors allez tu as raison alors il fait
de la pub pour un régime perd stade me
défonce tout ce qui lie à manger en lot
ça c'est faux dit la vérité a
entièrement te vois tu bouffes je ne
mange rien et vous avez d'ailleurs mis
des barres céréales et les bas côtés et
des amendes et vous avez encore eu un
deal financier avec ces gens là
et je penche plus d'une part oui à 0
sucre et des grains de beauté d'où mon
haleine ya 400 calories dans normalement
c'est vrai alors non mais franchement
vous avez bien maigri info mais vous
puer de la gueule
traversée vrai oui oui oui il info
benjamin a tellement maigri qui va
bientôt se faire recoller la peau sur
les muscles n'ont
pas su recoller la peau les muscles n'a
pas dit non
mais c'est vrai je connais pas de la
peau des yeux pour la maîtrise
mais c'est vrai pour raffermir vos 50 et
38 morts mais pourquoi je dis ça parce
que on dit mme banon voiture disent tout
à
la clinique à
madame on avait des impôts de la
clinique ah non c'est non pas du tout
non mais parce que lui aussi en avoir
aussi un
jardin qu'attali m'a dit tout à l'heure
que ça faisait un an et demi qui
s'entraînait assidûment à la boxe ou
quelqu'un sonne bon c'est mon seul
épisode
défoncer sur un ring de boxe à tout
moment sur six il vous fait pas peur
alors
mais elle était vraiment très très
sérieux ça fait
quarante une marque pour s'habiller pour
os pas le sport mécanique
guillaume vous y croyez pas du tout baki
ilkin défonce magazine quant à elle
s'est arrêtée c'est très bons
combattants non c'est un très bon
combattant et c'est pas parce qu'ils
voient rien ne va pas taper
[Applaudissements]
autre coup qu'il est chéri toutes les
équipes de tpm paix sont dépendantes des
tournois de paddle de syrie s'il ya un
tournoi il y à enregistrement tout le
matin ça s'est passé on est chassé pour
le texto d'hier soir je suis jamais
cachée oui donc demain matin on
enregistrait des arrivées puisque vous
avez un tournant oui c'est vraiment le
14 maintenant
pourquoi un est fou quoi monsieur génial
hein bah oui j'ai de carrière là bas de
liste la libye s'est fait tatouer défaut
grain de beauté sur le visage un
tien balance ah
bah c'est vrai ou pas maintenant oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et c'était quand ça avant-hier non mais
on n'a même pas martin regarder ah ouais
c'est bien ça
moi je les vois pas là mais me hamelle
et katchoo maquillage alors à quai ce
cas là bas parce que ya une certaine vie
où je suis pas maquillée et ya des
petits points convoyer regarde on
regardera ça tout à l'heure ce qui est
une très belle initiative
doit vous amener beaucoup de temps
comment je me tue à la tâche
et qui ont la bosse et les émissions que
tu fais là
heureusement en a mais alors là nous on
est tranquille manque un travail et
ouais et ouais non maison - ici m'a dit
t'es
sûrement symétrique alors jack s'appelle
laura c'est la marque elle brosse et
juste
[Applaudissements]
kelly
[Rires]
placement de produit tout chantier qui
attend
allez pas me chercher on l'a eu comme
jean ton non non non
genton voilà encore on a une vidéo à
disposition quoi croyez moi non non non
je suis déçu
je suis déçu guy
lux
les jeux parce que je suis en train de
lire c'est quoi c'est grave
j'ai une vidéo pourquoi te concernant
compromettantes bat toujours que
rarement des vidéos qui vont
naître et transpire là il n'est pas le
joli jeu très très mal il y a eu un
chroniqueur d'un guillaume qui à pécho
une chroniqueuse
c'est ici dans cette boîte les choux non
ça n'est pas quality street la boîte à
bonheur
c'est plutôt la boîte amoureux
guillaume genton à des assistantes
engagée uniquement pour lui faire des
pédicures
et vidéo à dispo donc oui de ses pouces
alors cet été effectivement j'ai pris
soin de mes pieds c'était la priorité
les pédicures et vous d'abord de cuques
[Rires]
et
donc je sais qui a filmé cette scène est
donc c'est sacha elbaz qui a filmé cette
scène puisqu'il est venu chez moi il m'a
filmée on va regarder
je vous donne mes courriers
toute personne voilée aux
soins du visage avant donc elles ont
fait des 2 mai à
la fête sur l'euro / l'oseille de
semaine moi je suis d'accord il ya
quelqu'un qui m'a dit ce matin mouais
bizar
toi siret uv chichement
guillaume genton c'est incroyable le
rythme de vie de nos jours c'est vrai
c'est fabien de lettres qui est venu me
dire ça ce matin dont elle est sympa
hein qui s'occupe de vos pieds ma
personne un branchement merci en tout
cas vous dire c'est que les couper ou
voulait ni mais vous n'avez pas de
toucher mes pieds des produits il avait
pas les pieds il a dilapidé les
sabres avec merci bravo et faites vous
plaisir quoi qu'il en ait faute de quoi
faites-vous plaisir tant qu'il en est
encore à l'empilement
non mais vraiment je vous le dis pas
vraiment bravo
des chaudes a chuté à chaque jeu d'actu
guillaume genton essaie d'amadouer les
équipes éditorialistes éditorial pour
avoir les réponses aux questions quitte
à les enlever
et c'est clairement pas il m'est arrivé
de lycéens tickets resto pour voir des
réponses
oui ça m'est arrivé une fois mais parce
que j'étais un peu voilà
restaurer le temps de préparer
l'émission dont j'ai donné quelques
tickets resto aux équipes en
10 ans chez h2o comme les 100 euros pour
le tout comme
quelques stocks accords aux bisons pas
tous les partis devraient donc ça c'est
alors et vous dit rien vous serrez vous
voulez vous dit ça comme ça aurait dit
alors le droit parce que là je viens de
lire un truc de ouf
un chroniqueur envoyé par erreur une
photo de moi nue
à une personne de la prod dix ans y sont
baissées non je pense que c'est là la
personne ait envoyé une vidéo nu de la
personne lui oui je pense et c'est ça
leur académie c'est quoi cette fontaine
histoire non non non non non non non
hubert
vous pourrez alors qu il sera au salon
du téton
non mais c'est pas vrai c'est vous c'est
[Rires]
bon c'est bon ça
son petit comme
c'est ma femme ah oui c'est ma femme est
bas mais en revanche elle ne veut pas se
retrouver sur le portable gendarmes de
l'équipe et j'ai fait une erreur en fait
je vais envoyer à quelqu'un équipe ah
oui
je vais aller au bout mais je voulais
pas le roi
joue et à l'envoyer à
savoir envoyer ça à une femme
évidemment les rennais s'étaient fait
ben ali merci mais c'est le il vaut
parfois
[Rires]
qu'il envoie cette photo
c'est la famille castaldi n'ont pas
toutes leurs têtes
quand on peut vivre tous les jours avec
de tels lieux on se dit voilà on n'est
pas tout à fait normal on n'a pas toute
sa tête mais là tout le reste
les faits macabres ita
lam et daniel mais c'est vrai que 20 kg
[Rires]
nadal
les points vie
vous en êtes où vous senti mentalement
ben ouais la réponse pour le dracula
personne qui passe
par celle conclue va vous appeler
[Applaudissements]
bah oui voilà mesdames coûte cher daniel
se débrouille très bien tout seul au nom
des
images
[Applaudissements]
si vous flânez
[Rires]
bombardé l'accueil
des bateaux comment
dire un jour tournoi à son chauffeur de
l'attendre double file devant le studio
tout le long de l'émission a créé des
bouchons voilà
c'est faux c'est vraiment falloir qu'on
se passe c'est vrai j'étais derrière la
voiture ça veut dire que c'est vrai et
puis on la voit une voiture à les
dialectes et pourvoir seront permis non
messieurs plaît c'est vrai cette
histoire c'est entièrement faux c'est
arrivé une fois qu'ils attendent en
double file parce qu'il donnait un pull
un j'ai décidé de changer plus l'honneur
des mamans vous avez décidé de changer
ça va vous sinon
amis là bas je vais faire ça mais oui la
chauffeur
différence entre guillemets à shopper
bouderra chauffage
[Rires]
c'est dingue a alors pourquoi raymond
hains a branché valérie bénaïm l'année
dernière par message privé elle l'a
éconduit poliment quelques renan c'est
peut-être var attendait c'était en
quelle période les confinements
alors là août ouais mais précieux orbite
basse est respectée
on peut discuter ça ne s'était en tout
cas autochtone a hérité la vérité at on
a mis tout frais alors alors très
gentiment il m'a dit parce que c'était
l'époque où je venais un tout petit peu
moi donc donc il m'a il m'a dit ça ça va
je suis là ça serait bien que tu
reviennes tu me more tue pas dire donc
avec des petits coeurs et tout ça donc
moi j'ai renvoyé ou bien la vérité chez
oh mais maintenant mais c'est normal de
prendre la vérité galère il dit la
vérité toi qui connais non mais sa
voisine d'où ils avaient un peu la dalle
mais
raymond et ses hasards bon jour
automatique
partez pas touché quelque chose et les
bacs et le val d'arros de partout ça
fait rire une série de jeux vous dit
tout oui je suis pas moi j'vote
meilleurs amis et pas qu'à moi injures
un qui est là aussi on voyait qu'à
quelqu'un qui est une amie à moi j radio
mois des messages et rania pas le
serment d'hippocrate
même si c'est des collègues
juste quand jradi nous a répondu vous
avez rien compris ce que vous a dit bah
dévoile pour notre siège 3 v
a répondu un truc à leur ego de truc à
lui dit tu crois
alors il ya toujours le prétexte
fallacieux d'un match oui c'est vrai
donc un art à vue on a bien joué qu est
ce que tu en penses lui les matchs de
foot ils sont bousculés ces maîtres
début
très élégant est beau et ben c'est sûr
bah oui a beaucoup tourné avec heures
voilà prêt très sympathique voilà le
tableau mais on sent qu'ils
il adhère
cette boîte appliquée est incroyable ce
soit et j'ai gardé le meilleur hélas à
la un couple une galoche il n'y a pas
dans maman non
mais non c'est puisque la gale sera dans
un instant pour l'instant on continue
une fois daniel moreau a été tellement
désagréable avec son chauffeur rubber
que celui ci l'a laissé planté seul sur
la route ah oui c'est vrai
non mais c'est un c'était un fou mais
sur la route mais sur la nationale il
voulait me laisser descendre sur la
nationale ah ouais mais c'est pas parce
que j'étais désagréable c'est que équipe
ou
sur la nationale 10 et le samedi sauf si
c'est compliqué mais en fait j'ai pu
faire une fausse manoeuvre sa annuler la
course et comme puisque je suis pas
douée et donc mais pour s'annuler vous
descendez et on était sur des
nationalismes alors pas fait
[Rires]
perso
je me dis moi mon décolleté je leur
envoie moi j'ai il est garni c'est
isabelle qui m'arrive this way de
63,3 sont les spurs office pour aller
jusqu'à la fin de la cérémonie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le seul mariage ils ne distribuent
pas des dragées
[Applaudissements]
mazel tov mabrouk ali
alors il pas là ah c'est sûr delphine on
fera quand elle est là a reconnu
nasrallah
ça non
c'est incroyable alors je ne veux pas de
ne pas savoir d'où vient sa ou en enjeu
où je vais le lire au combat sera autre
chose et il va sur ya pas de vidéo je
vous dis rien du tout mais je vous dis
d'accord vous des galas régionaux joli
nom je vous ai dit il faut le dire cyril
hanouna m'a roulé une pelle et quelqu'un
vous a filmé à bon c'est vrai la vidéo
tout seul
abbas il ya une vidéo une vidéo à homs
et à l'humour il ya une vidéo
des gens dans sa cousine on jouera
compte maintenant c'était à 10 ans était
à 10 ans en fait j'étais chroniqueur
chez morandini à l'époque que j'embrasse
vous étiez invité vous commenciez tpm
parce que là je veux dire
on s'était jamais vu bref vous m'avez vu
ou à y rouler une pelle non non je vois
qu'avant ça m'étonne pas et que la
pagaille alors en attendant il faut
qu'on voie ça commence à voir sa place
donc au bout de six ans quitte france
télé me
battre
c'est un but
je vous revois dans la même salle de gym
mais j'ai
un petit mot pour guillaume assez il
débute à la télé c'est un petit jeune
québec je trouve que c'est un très beau
départ merci déjà physiquement je trouve
que tu te détache des autres
vous avez des liens familiaux
il ya un petit air puisqu'on était on
est cousin de du danemark ce soit
c'est sympa ça veut dire un très bel
épiderme à l'époque je ne sais pas ce
que j'ai fait que cette barbe la très
bizarre mais vous c'était très beau
merci mais vous étiez là bas tout a
changé général serge est passé de pabos
avocat je sais pas quand c'est possible
mais la raison enfin la taxe est passé
de pabos moi pas non non non ce n'est
pas beau mais parce que vous aimez
restauration de gaieté aux
[Rires]
braves au radon vous êtes un sacré
snipers c est pâques ici quant à ce
qu'on m'a dit mais call me toise et
surtout à la prochaine matthieu
delormeau refuse de participer à une
émission présentée par castaldi ou
bernard montiel non c'est l'amérique
c
si des porcs
non c'est faux c'est vrai c'était faux
c'est vrai c'est vrai tu es faut
des matches je dis la vérité
c'est pas non c'était ce week end c'est
pas ça c'est que je non je me réserve
pour vous d'accord mais vite ma vérité
mais non mais non mais ça me paraissait
bizarre non
si elle faisait paraissait bizarre des
dettes non mais je me suis dit bon thé
animateurs tu passes chroniqueur
apprécié tout devient chroniqueur de
chroniqueurs toualbi chroniqueur du
chroniqueur de chroniquer rien
abandonner la descente aux enfers mais
la casquette fois l'animateur
oui mais c'est pour ça c'était l'époque
j'étais même maintenant j'ai changé mais
oui on est la vérité tu m'emmerdes
je vais regretter avec vous ses amis nos
mains ouais ouais tu es dans une perte
lance une perche alors ne lance pas père
a
un nom à la non mais il peut faire un
vendredi ouvert à tous qui n'en veut pas
ou le 6 est à l'écouté me fait penser
justement castaldi est persuadé qu
montiel fait baisser les audiences du 6
à 7
alors c'est vrai sur cible et c'est vrai
c'est défendre à la barre et furent les
jeunes
c'est drôle on m'a dit le contraire
autant on t'a menti
c'est un tic dans les mois chauds qu'une
j'ai aucun comme compétition et bien et
valérie aussi c'est très bien c'est pas
grave je les vois
je vois passer je m'en tape est bon on
tira sur toute la lozère de cotecna
[Rires]
ça doit être ça rabbo a rejoint jean
n'est plus là des deux côtés c'est la
question d'ailleurs merci on vous a pas
posé la question s'en fout royalement
aller question tient alors ça a à chaque
pause de l'émission benjamin castadi
appelle sa femme pour lui demander s'il
est bien à l'antenne
non c'est pas vrai si si c'est le
boulanger cela faire appel à chaque pot
c'est vrai ça va si vous êtes bien les
la vérité ne m'aurait pas veux pas me
demandez moi moi pendant la
gv it d'avoir votre regardons être
parfois je demande si ça si ça va c'est
ça va encore dire que j'ai pas un
million ça ça dépend des fois des
volumes étaient mauvais et les comités
de l'inde en tout cas sans fenêtre merci
bravo m
german ce qu'il voit pas du tout quand
on lui ment
à les gros dossiers bon alors le crédit
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord la la
la la la
non la semaine prochaine c'est chaud
patate
après c'est ici
j'ai ici
le nom de la prochaine nouvelle star
la tentative estatof
deux
chroniqueurs génie bien chroniqueur
chronique des âmes donc 2 ha non un
homme
et une femme
jordan dare dollars je vais vous dire
souple et lens calme l'heure est grave
s'il vous plaît deux chroniqueurs
aurait eu une aventure
lors d'un déplacement
avec les équipes je sais je vous donnais
juste je vais juste vous donner un
indice
parmi les chroniqueurs
sus concernés
pour l'un d'eux
allez petit dieu une grosse poitrine
royal en attentant bas problème n'est
pas le pays au voyage c'est là le
problème est
rien je dis bien qu' à forniquer
maintenant on va [ __ ]
aux trousses du chemin vous prenez
l'écouté j'ai dit que la personne avait
des petits dieux et des gros ça veut pas
dire que c'est pas le genre
même si c'est vrai que la déception
il est encore temps de recul et cyril je
ne recule jamais vous allez brisé une
famille
brisé une famille ja briserait plus pour
lui ce sera pas la première fois
les choses que concorde peux vous dire
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] c'est terrible mal
de reins castaldi vous serez toujours le
bienvenue à la maison
je vous demande juste un truc quand vous
prenez votre douche et un soutien
benjamin castadi on va dire oui il ya
une rumeur oui
et sur cette rumeur elle vient
de vous un homme m'a dit que l'équipe
m'a dit que ça venait de vous mais en
fait un béni oui oui il est fougueux
fujimoto poucave il se vante posée au
cac avait on pouvait
benjamin castaldi est ce vrai alors je
vous le dis ça n'a pas du tout forniquer
mais il ya eu un bisou non
je sais que tu as toi
ces anglais l'autre kg bouquin direct
non parce que parce que c'est parce que
ces bailleurs défense alors je vous
raconte tout nous sommes en l'air alors
ces tempêtes et surtout non non non non
je ne vais pas chamakh castaldi choquant
même pour l'instant
tant sur thur avale sa salive
tu es sur bâbord avait cassé dit que tu
veux raconter ça bah oui bien sûr mais
tu es sur wii est ce que tu veut
peut-être enlever ton slip quelque chose
oui et non mais benjamin castaldi ah oui
toi je le rappelle à roche je vais dire
moi de ce que je vais dire ce que tu vas
nous garde art est il qu en laponie
aulas
en laponie fait très froid
et benjamin castaldi
avait comme tout le monde un petit et un
mister freeze dans le slip comme la
berline j'adore une amie était avec nous
en laponie elle nous a rejoint elle nous
a rejoint exactement j'avais oublié on
était bien de le dire un indice delphine
je vous racontais en laponie qui
arrivait de mehdi était loin a été dans
une chambre dans une tour dans un tour
d'ivoire ne voyait personne mais cette
chance allez eu cette chance si on a eu
la chance aussi d'avoir loin
il y avait ma chambre grandes chambres
très belle à l'autre bout on va dire on
veut dire à palais
avait m'a
dit alors je vous racontais c'est une
catastrophe j'ai eu des paletots
[Applaudissements]
à chaque fois à chaque fois qu'ils
arrivent et le tu as l'air quelques
palmiers l'hérault s'est
mis des pétales de rose partout dans ma
chambre c'est un enfer pour dormir je me
les réveiller avec des pétales pas
supportable en tout cas je sentais très
très bon
et en face de ma chambre
il y avait la chambre de delphine
wespiser mais vraiment on était face à
face donc je savais tout ce qui se
passait dans la chambre d'en face et
entre qui sort et j'ai entendu un moment
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
benjamin castaldi
est soupçonné
d'avoir eu
une aventure avec gatineau
en laponie
laponie la peau nos d'après noces
si j'étais toi je me ferais tout
ça shake dat hinzpeter essayé de
m'appeler ya un instant je viendrai à la
la je pense donc delphine wespiser et en
flip
delphine wespiser velud savoir peut-être
la vérité je vous la donne et
2,7 les deux versions du bien la fox
news j'y vais alors petite heure gros
seins
je vous rappelle je rappelle que vous
étiez en laponie ciridd bien sûr il n
est que votre jeu préféré en laponie de
bouleverser les règles et de faire
notamment le jeu des chambres
et vous avez décidé de tirer au sort les
champs pour que chacun dorment avec les
uns et les autres voilà en plus j'avais
une chambre de merde je vous le dis
c'était la plus petite avec un tout
petit écran comme ça vous l'avez vu
petit mais les tpe
dont le tirage au sort il se trouve que
ce qui devait dormir ensemble c'était
castaldi et wespiser mais moi je savais
que derrière cette mise en scène cette
mascarade mais tout ça pour la
télévision c'était pour rigoler pour du
jeu pas du tout baltes pas moi je
croyais ne croyait plus ils ne croisent
et je croyais pas mais
tu crois pas que j'étais pour de rire
bon je vais donc me coucher dans mon
petit nid dans cette petite chambre
merdique calmez vous s'il vous plaît et
qui frappe à ma porte delphine wespiser
aulas s'est elle dit sur la tête des
gosses c'est la vérité
[Rires]
donc si vous payez note parce que les
gens veulent savoir les français doivent
savoir j'ai fait le sil vous plait pas
je me dis donc qu'est ce que je peux
lire dormir avec toi je dis maman tu
peux pas dormir avec moi en fait parce
que c'était pour deux c'était pour de
faux c'était pour rigoler mais moi je
veux dormir dans cette chambre et syrie
qui l'a dit quand ça
allait vraiment pourquoi le règlement
règlement savait déjà les cheveux que
cyril puisse faire sa séquence quand il
manque avec un petit peu ennuyeux quand
même parce que voilà c'est une autre
version
bref que bref donc j'ai dû expliquer
gentiment y avait un canapé que si elle
voulait dormir si vous voulez dormir à
donner aux fumeurs vous aimez gueule
c'est important quand même à nous
enfoncer
c'est donc logique et il s'est donc
couché sur nous sur couchée sur le
canapé quoi qui n'a pas été le lui
annoncer mon lit quand même vos
commentaires
elle s'est couchée dans cette date dans
ce cas la paix et woods académique défi
que que fais-tu débat j'attends mais je
lis tu attends quoi de voir le loup
amis j'attends cette année
n'envoyez
dit non mais c'est pas possible
c'est et deviennent
donc à venise et attend qu'on fasse la
séquence des mes delphine qui n'y aura
pas de séquences que tout le monde dort
donc ça sert à rien que tu fais donc je
lui ai gentiment dit que ça devait bien
de coucher dans ma chambre j'ai pu
repartir ailleurs bien volontiers dans
quel but il obtient absolument rien
c'est pas léger vent et je me vante pas
du tout je vous demande pas du tout à
tel point que cette histoire a fuité un
petit peu et que ça a mis un petit peu
en colère ma femme a expliqué ce qui
s'était passé ben d'accord a expliqué
les bonnes femmes marc accrue et ma
femme m'a cru parce que ma femme me
crois parce que j'aime bien courir la
balle est bien sympa
voilà je suis actuellement elle est en
train de faire ses
[Rires]
parts voilà je peux je peux en revanche
et je sais que fort de cet échec dans ma
chambre je sais qu'après elle a fait le
tour d'autres chambres sur l'octroi du
ltte de l'émission est il au téléphone
delphine elle est là elle est au
téléphone
alors oui moi nordine ce qu'elle a dit
delphine halle et au téléphone delphine
tu veux réagir
de laponie à strasbourg en passant par
mulhouse on sort des jeunes est un peu
loin je suis un peu loin pour me
défendre
les petits coquins faire ça quand je
suis pas là en fait alors delphine
sache-le on va préférer le faire quand
t'étais pas là
mais en fait quand même moi je croyais
que tu étais là en plus aujourd'hui
delphine uns et pas les jolies pas non
plus on m'appelle peu un combat nist oui
alors
qu'est ce que j'ai à faire dans cette
affaire
dans leur dessine
pour la cohésion de l'équipe et tous de
faire des roulements de chambre
de faire un vrai défi comme un parti
comme ça c'est l'autre pour des
séquences où les cecos et en os mis un
doigt là où marrante et tout ça et est
donc by ap une impulsion donc moi est la
première chambre que j'ai trouvé ben
j'ai toqué la première chambre qui m'a
ouvert effectivement c'était benjamin du
coup je suis allé j'ai dit bah écoutes
je sais pas s'il veut qu'on fasse un
truc vas-y marché soit amputé d'un
deuxième lit et tout et puis moi ça me
dérange pas de dormir dans la chambre d
autres enfin puisque je ne vois pas le
mal moi je dors dans la ville d'austin
de ventura c'est vrai elle dort très
souvent avec des garçons non mais je
vous jure que non mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai ces maladies enfin y'a pas de
quoi la voile avec mes amis du coup
oui tout on a un peu parlé c'est un
marathon
et au bout d'un moment
il ne répondait plus et c'est ton avis
comment ça vous plaît
ces propos sont donc il n'y a rien eu
rien merci on verra quand même sur 7
[Applaudissements]